hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the first uh sorry
further from the second round of the
European individual Championship it is
Max varmeadam versus Olga badelka and
the game features the move that wasn't
actually played in the game uh but it's
such a spectacular idea Max tweeted
about it on Twitter saying that he spent
40 minutes in this position but he still
couldn't figure it out uh but that's
where you guys come in you will have a
chance to solve this beautiful position
uh so let's check it out so max with the
white pieces opens with C4 he goes for
the English opening we have Knight to F6
by Olga Knight the C3 e6d4 and Bishop to
B4 we have the nimso Indian defense
Knight to F3 the three Knights variation
castles Bishop to G5 and the H6 Bishop
H4 Pawn to C5 so this is all very
standard stuff uh nothing new being
played here C captures with e captures
and pawn to D5 Rook to C1 Knight to C6
and now finally challenging the bishop
with fonte A3 so Bishop back t7 uh we
have pawned the C5 uh sort of an
anti-positional move but it has been
played before by some very strong
players Knight the E4 and now we have a
trade Bishop captures Queen captures and
now Bishop to E2 uh there is a very
famous game where Bishop to B5 was
played uh Magnus Carlsen played it
against Hikaru Nakamura in 2016 in your
next move it was a it was a Blitz game
uh the game ended in a draw but here we
have Bishop to E2 we have rooked the d8
and now uh again uh the position has
been reached before uh vitashek had it
against Vladimir kramnik Martino we
chatted against gelfand in in both of
the Games castles was played but here we
have pawned the B4 by Max and it is now
as of move 13 that we have a a
completely new game so here you might
consider Ponte 6 to stop B5 but uh if
there's no need there then there's no
need Olga just plays Pawn to E5 uh
sacrificing a pawn uh Knight captures
with Knight captures and D captures on
E5 now Ponte A5 now challenging this
queen side expansion we have castles and
eight captures on B4 we have eight
characters Knight captures on C3 Rook
characters and now reclaiming the pawn
with Queen captures on E5 with Rook to
E3 now attacking the queen queen F4 and
now Queen to D2 preparing a nice rock
lift uh preparing to bring the Rook
Intel game but also uh threatening the
tricky rookie to check which would
blunder the queen so of course the
Bishop T is sex stopping this while
developing the bishop with G3 Queen to
F6 and now Rook the F3 Queen back to E5
and now Rook the E1 threatening some
nasty discoveries but just Rook to A1
Olga wants to trade a pair of Rooks off
the board rookie 3 we have Rook
characters on E1 with check Queen
captures and now Queen to B2
uh we have Bishop to D3 now uh and King
the f8 now King to f8 is a very
important move because here uh Olga
realized that the king belongs on the
queen side the problem with the moon
like Rook to A8 if you want to play
something like Rook day one uh White
would probably immediately win with Rook
captures on E6 now you can't do this if
you play Rook to A1 uh then Rook the E8
is Checkmate as the bishop covers the H7
square and you if you accept the Rook
then Queen captures with check King to
h8 and now Queen F5 and you will not
survive this it's uh gonna be incredibly
difficult like G6 Queen captures you can
bring the queen back now Queen is six
you go after this Pawn you play B5 C6 so
uh it would be a miracle if black
survived this so instead King to f8
uh she wants to bring the king over to
the queen side uh we have Rook the E2
now attacking the queen now the same
idea isn't as potent because now uh the
Black Wing can just go back with uh with
a move like Queen to F6 so instead we
have Rook to E2 and now Queen to D4 we
have Queen to D2 uh and now Rook to A8
and here uh you don't want to wait for a
move like Rook to A4 then you might lose
the B4 Pawn so Bishop to B5 offers a
queen trade Rook the A1 with check King
to G2 and now Queen to G4 we have Rook
to E1 uh offering a trade and Rook
captures we have Queen capture Sunny one
king the E7 and now King to G1 getting
off of this nasty diagonal uh before
um uh deciding what to do next we have
Queen to D4 and now Bishop back to F1
now you you wanna position your queen
somehow to defend the C Pawn so you can
play B5 and then Advance the pawn to C6
so Queen to B1 uh sorry uh King to D7
bring the king over to the queen side
now Queen to B1 H5 uh here Olga wants to
play H4 and then maybe even H3 Queen to
B3 and now we have Pawn to H4 and now uh
Queen to A4 with check uh here uh how do
you how do you continue this King to C7
Queen to A5 check King to C8 and now
Queen to B6 here maybe the simplest way
is Queen A3 this um uh protects the C5
Pawn or rather once you put B5 C5 will
be protected and maybe this is the the
way to go let's say h characters H
captures a black play something fun to
B5 and you are you are pushing uh
however he played Queen to B6 and now
it's very tricky how do you play this uh
you can get a pretty much an instant
draw here with Queen to D1 the problem
is the thread of Bishop H3 is too great
and you have to settle for a draw C6
characters captures and now you're just
gonna check the uh check the black king
uh pretty much forever King seven Queen
to C5 after King 38 and so on so instead
after this queen to B6 uh she she didn't
go for Queen to D1 Olga played H3 uh
which is uh which looks incredibly
strong but it also uh loses the game
here she allowed Pawn to B5 now comes
Queen to E5 and pawn to C6 it seems like
she's defending everything Queen to C7
but look at this queen to C5 King to B8
and now the almost the star move of the
game Pawn to B6 a beautiful Pawn
Sacrifice by Max uh where you have to
play Queen captures on C6 uh so Queen
captures on C6 and now look at this
queen to f8 with check now you can't
block with the queen if you block with
the queen then it's the uh the the queen
D6 check and now you get checkmated King
8 Queen day three checking goes here and
this will now be Checkmate the phone
covers the C7 Square
uh so she blocks would bash up the C8
and she is up material the problem is uh
it's completely winning now Bishop
captures an H3 now you can't move the
queen otherwise you blunder the bishop
on f8 uh on C8 and now comes spawn to D4
and there is there is such a beautiful
move here in this position uh like I
said Max uh spent 40 minutes pondering
on the position but but he failed to see
it uh however you guys notice here you
guys can do it uh feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Max uh while
I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
elusive idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
to all the way to D7 that's the move
look at it it's it's disgusting and yet
beautiful what a move uh the problem now
is that uh the queen is attacked and you
can't really move the queen anywhere
from the defense of the bishop but
that's that's your only move you have to
play something like Queen captures and
then this will be uh uh Queen captures
on C8 King A7 you're gonna be down a
full piece uh the problem is if you
capture the bishop you are no longer
attacking the B6 Pawn what black really
wants to do is that after uh White plays
something black wants to capture on B6
but now white can play Queen to A3 and
because the bishop is now stuck on C8 uh
there's no defense against Queen to A7
Checkmate whatever you do it's just
Queen to A7 Checkmate unless you're
you're being weird with some like Queen
to A4 uh but okay after D4 Max missed
the idea he played Bishop to F5 and now
we have Queen to C1 with check King to
G2 and queen to C6 with check now uh
Olga bounces back in the game uh we have
Ponte F3 and now Pawn to D3
uh she wants to give up the D3 Pawn for
the uh for the B6 pawn and uh it's it's
definitely the way to go the problem
with a move like G6 is that now you can
just trade everything captures captures
captures captures and uh the the problem
is let's say something like King F2 King
to D7 you want to go after this Pawn the
black king has no plan because if you go
if you go for uh uh for the B6 spawn
then H4 G4 H5 and then the the H Pawn is
Unstoppable uh if you don't if you go to
the king side then uh White will just um
uh you know push pawns on the king side
then capture on D4 then Captain B7 so
you can't go uh be everywhere at once
and the D4 Pawn is simply too weak so
that's the problem with a move like G6
in the game D3 was played and here at
Max traded Bishop captures with Queen
captures and now Queen captures on G7
and now Max is up a pawn uh we have
Queen to E3 and now Queen to C3 now he's
up upon his King is a little bit safer
and he will of course try to push this
for when Pawn to B5 you cannot capture
because the queen would hang so Queen to
C2 preparing Queen to E2 we have Pawn to
B4 and now Ponte H for Max starts
pushing the pawn as well Bishop P6 with
Queen to E2 and now Queen to D4 with
Ponte H5 Ponte B3 now it's a race H6 B2
Ponte H7 and now King to C7
uh so okay the the queen is covering the
h8 square but now Bishop to B1 with
Queen to G7 and now Queen to E3 uh we
have King to D7 and now Queen to A7 with
check King to d8 and now Queen to B8
with check and now the problem is if the
king moves then you just bring the queen
into the game so Bishop to C8 was played
and now Bishop to F5 and he was in this
position and move 63 that Olga badelka
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so uh truly a
remarkable game and especially that
um that the bishop to D7 move that
didn't happen but luckily you guys have
found it as you are incredible chess
players so uh here you resign because
um uh there's no defense against Queen
captures and see it whatever you play
it's still Queen captures Instead The
Black Queen cannot defend uh and even if
you try something pretty like bring your
queen into a game hoping uh to deflect
white somehow uh still just Queen
characters and see it with Chair King
moves anywhere and now Bishop capture
some B1 you're gonna be upper full piece
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely played by by both
of them but it is Max who emerges
Victorious uh too bad for that Bishop to
D7 idea it would have been uh Max has so
many so many uh epic games I I I
wouldn't say would be his Immortal but
it would be it would be a very nice move
uh so yeah really hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank the Bernard domini a
funky Minecraft house YouTube uh sakanka
travel and tour safaris and Jordan Smith
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing uh the
coverage of this wonderful event uh
until it finishes uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and uh I I really
enjoyed the uh the the the fight
yesterday between
um uh between Cyril and and Jon Jones it
was uh it was it was quite quite an
event uh so if any of you uh have seen
it you know do share your comments on
that as well see you soon